turning to sports tonight we are just a
few days away from the raiders regular
season opener at allegiant stadium to
get into the game you have to have had
your kovid 19 vaccine so the team is
making sure everything runs smoothly
madison kimbrough joins us live from
allegiant tonight with more on the first
day of alternate vaccine screening matt
madison
yeah so it actually just ended but from
1 to 6 p.m fans can come here to lot b
where you can see this tent behind me
this is where they can come for their
alternate screening to ensure access to
monday night's game against the
baltimore ravens
the whole point to these alternate
screenings is for fans to avoid long
wait times and delays ahead of monday
night's game fans are required to use
the clear health pass to upload their
vaccination info these lines are for
those fans unable to use the app whether
that be due to being partially
vaccinated or if a fan has a vaccine
that isn't supported by the app or is an
out of state visitor if a fan has a
digital vaccine card that is unable to
be uploaded or if a fan is bringing a
vaccinated or partially vaccinated 12 to
13 year old guest fans we spoke to in
line today were all for the experience
and just happy to be going to the first
home game of the season it feels great
i'm having a ball
we got to keep living
i mean you got to keep living i'm just
coming here to get cleared so i can get
in the game with no problem
love my raiders want to be supporting
them on monday night and it's so easy
you know so many people are sick and
dying and all i got to do is get the
shot on monday vaccinations will be
offered for fans on the spot ahead of
the game
those 11 years old or younger will be
the only people allowed entry into the
game without vaccination requirements
again the game starts on monday at 5 p.m
against the baltimore ravens so we are
all looking forward to that reporting
live from allegiant stadium madison
kimbrough 8 news now